ça aurait presque pu être un sketch de
l'époque de la rose rouge n'est ce pas
yves robert on retrouve toujours les
mêmes gestes les mêmes attentions et il
ya une forme classique de de la
recherche pour femme usée les autres
pour faire rire les autres pour
distraire les autres certainement
saint-germain-des-prés 45 quatre frères
qui ne le sont pas il y en a quand même
de vrais arrive des champs elysées où
ils ont créé les gueux au paradis c'est
la grande époque du flore ou sartre
prenait son crème ou simone de beauvoir
écrivait ses romans ou juliette gréco ne
chantait pas encore eu en chantant dans
aurions le tueur avec leurs collants
dessiné par mal classe déjà et puis
c'est la rose rouge où ils prennent
pension les voici à 34 ans il y à 34 ans
georges et andré bélec paul touraine
françois soubeyrand et au piano hubert
de jacques s'ils jouent les exercices de
style de queneau 900 x et chante du
sartre
mais bon
ça fait deux
mais quand la petite marche vers le fait
que tu vois résoudre à sa mort larry
nouvel os
grèce le menton triplé le bus tram à
chenilles
en touraine
vienne viel cie maillot ils sont
soigneux 136 paire d'escarpins le chant
ne fatigue pas la semelle et 420
moustache certains les avaient naturel
ils sont montés sur 953 scène ont été
applaudis par 38 nations et ont parcouru
4 millions de kilomètres en voiture en
avion en bateau
je pense qu'ils n'ont jamais fait
tourner un cheval pendant que vous vous
installez pour chanter votre chanson je
crois qu'on pourrait quand même un peu
évoqué l'époque de la rose rouge
l'époque oui vous devait être un frère
jacques basset vous avez pas l'exercice
de style c'est un spectacle monté
ensemble et alors qu'est ce qu'il
faisait que je fais objets n'importe
quoi surtout c'est à dire la recherche
tout ce qu'on avait envie le résumé des
armes provenaient de la mise en scène
qu'on ne savait pas que s'appeler comme
ça on fait de la mise en scène
collective maintenant on s'en aperçoit
maintenant que la mise en scène
collective mais on ne savait pas quelle
après il est trop modeste ou le dire
parce que c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de
monter exercice de style
il nous a dit j'ai trouvé un truc
formidable lisez le on l'a lu un à
dubrulle
or on verra mais si si si vous verrez il
nous a convaincus il nous a obligés et
cet exercice de style a fait notre
renommée dans le monde entier parce que
partout on est passé on a trouvé des
gens qui nous ont dit méchante et
d'autobus vous rappelez chanter
l'autobus
or c'était une chanson dont il avait
demandé à pierre philippe de faire la
musique et qui faisait partie de son
spectacle
mais alors comment se fait-il maintenant
que vous avez décidé de faire vos adieux
vous êtes quand même assez ingambe en
bonne santé tout ça on ne sera pas forcé
de vous chasser de la ferme
pourquoi est ce que vous faites vos
adieux au pour des raisons personnelles
je veux dire c'est pas parce que ça
marche mal c'est bon parce qu'on trouve
pas de répertoire c'est parce qu'on a
décidé à un autre âge de nous arrêter
d'ici quelques mois dit sylvain à 25
mois en commençant par paris dans
quelques jours et puis pour reprendre
des activités que nous aimions que nous
refaire avant d'être frères jacques
c'est comme un feu d'artifice ça
s'arrête par un bouquet faut pas
attendre de retomber en décrépitude pour
s'arrêter vaut mieux s'arrêter avant que
le métier nous arrête alors qu'est ce
que vous allez faire quand vous serez
arrêtés une dépression des fours si je
puis dire
et vous moi je la peinture de l'économie
politique
sérieusement vous voulez entrer dans un
ministère pour me pour mon plaisir
personnel
ça c'est à la maison oui oui suivre une
des cours de facultés aussi ça me
plairait vous voulez pas fonder une
chorale avec vos enfants
non et si on chantait volontiers alors
on va chanter les fesses les fesses vous
chanter avec nous
altrad dimanche et comme agricole tient
particulièrement à que les mères
tu voi imposer la paix
et vous d'en tomber si bas que ça oui
c'est sûr
c'est faux si vous avez remarqué on
dirait que depuis quelques années tous
on entend parler s'est il y en a des
routes via des plates
il y en ad faire mieux l'année flasque
parler il y en a besoin soit amusé
déprimé et on a deux autres sociétés
bon ben là une chose de réglée si on
parle prend les verts au moins ils
soient pas jouées rien à tirer ses
gaules à l'été soit nos sujets
tout de même pas commencé à céder des
points à lewiston s'envole
et il ya ce que vous pensez quand ils
font autre chose que vous aimez de quoi
est ce qu on pourrait parler
il y en a deux sur la même taille qui
sont en mal
y'en a quand même y en a qu'on t'a y en
a qui brûle toutes les étapes des coûts
des flux qui passe devant mais c'est
toujours bien pour la ville il ya
toujours le score des prix pose un doigt
de son passeport mais qu'on les aime
pour les impatients ou serait pas
d'accord la réticence à l'envers ça va
bien cinq minutes mais le monde on est
écoeurés des flèches à alors pensons à
notre sujet on en parle plus on s est
dit on à c'est lui qui chantait le bol
on parlerait plus l'ours commençons à
vau l'eau
rien qu'à le boire ça fait quelque chose
qui dure y en a des mots y en a beaucoup
de petits trop folle mspb qui tombe pour
qu'on les fautes des timides et
effrontée ce qui vous regarde les laisse
au nez mais qu'on les aime qu'on les
aime obtient la réponse n'est ce pas là
avec les frères jacques que se terminera
cette dernière édition d'antenne 2010 de
la semaine merci messieurs et nous vous
retrouverons sur scène avec beaucoup de
plaisir pendant les nombreux mois de vos
adieux